on the mound for the pods
joe musgrove comes into today's game
with a 4-6 record a 2.28
era chris taylor will lead off starting
at second base today for dave roberts
3-2 swinging a mix slider up in the zone
and taylor strikes out one away in the
top of the first it's a good start for
joe musgrove a nice round of boos for
max muncie came off the il last night
had a right oblique strain three and two
is swung on and missed strike three
back-to-back case for musgrove got
taylor with a slider now he gets muncie
with a curveball two outs in the top of
the first
justin turner coming up two balls two
strikes to turner here it comes and he
gets
hit by a pitch on a breaking ball that
didn't break on the mound is trevor
bauer he has been terrific for his ball
club all year has gone at least six
innings in all but one start
now fernando tatis jr
seventh in the league at 285 first in
the league with 22 home runs and second
with 50 runs batted in 2-2 got him
swinging with a fast spot at 97.
a little salute from both of them right
there
two down in the first inning and here is
jake cronenworth
high drive right field
we
are still in the ground zone
jake crowdenworth the trifecta home runs
one in each of the three games against
the dodgers oh this is the crown zone
that's jake
from rake farm
and now
the guy that bauer has called his dad
manny machado coming up
hydra deep left field for manny
padres go back to back
manny machado with his 12th of the year
first connor worth then machado
back to back jacks
padres laid it two nothing
smith leads it off here for la in the
second inning
two balls and two strikes to will smith
here's the pitch and right at the knees
strike three call that's a fastball
out number one in the top of the second
and already three k's for musgrove one
on the slider one on a curveball and now
one on a heater
two gun and victor caratini coming in
the one two
but a breaking ball swing and a miss is
a strike three and caratini is down on
strikes
chris struck out in his first at-bat
3-2 pitch is on the outside edge strike
three call
musgrove makes quick work of the dodgers
here in the top of the third inning a
one two three frame and he caps it with
a k his fourth strike out of the night
and joe musgrove is leading it off the
1-2
got him swinging
third strikeout for bauer one gone in
the third
and tommy pham is coming up
fam has found off a couple of two
pitches
can't get a hold of this one slider for
strike three back to back cage to open
the third
and here comes cronenworth who homered
in his first at-bat
now chronoworth pops it up
left side of the infield turner's camped
underneath it makes the catch and that
will end the inning
no runzo hits a walk one man left will
go to the fourth padres two and the
dodgers nothing the dodgers with their
first legitimate threat of the night
first and third with one out and will
smith
is coming up
line drive left center field it'll drop
in front of grisham to get the dodgers
on the board
will smith drives home max muncie and
it's 2-1
the dodgers back to within one as matt
baby steps in and he bounced back to the
box in his first hat back
fastball hitting the ground to first
hosmer goes to second one tatissa jumps
through the gets by and this game is
tied
he winds up all the way up at second
it's 2-2 on a throwing here from tatis
here's gavin lux
where the runner on second base and he
swings the first pitch hits a comebacker
musgrove snags it fires to first base in
time and the inning is over
i think joe didn't realize that was the
third out he was checking runners
looking all over the place
and uh now he realizes oh good the
inning's over and he departs and we'll
get checked by the first base umpire
mark carlson so the dodgers tie it with
a couple of runs here in the fourth
inning
and uh kind of a weird play to get home
the second one but the damage limited
and after three and a half tied at two
machado homered in his first at-bat
three straight fastballs this time and
he's down quickly
shoots a smile out at bauer appreciating
the plan that he had for him that time
we're lined out to center his first time
power struck out machado
he strikes out hosmer with an elevated
cutter two gone
bring up the light-hitting muskrove with
the bases loaded and two out
bowers 77th pitch
joe musgrove awaits here it comes and
down he goes ball strike three and that
will end the inning
seventh strike out of the game for power
no runs one hit
and three left
tied at two as we head to the fifth what
our base is empty for power
swing and a miss and bauer badly pulled
on the slider strikes out
five strikeouts for joe musgrove two
down
tommy pham oh for two tonight one for 10
in this series
starting in right tonight with no milky
bets
takes extra bases away from fam for the
first out of the fifth
one out fernando tatis junior coming up
got him with a tailing fast small two
out
corner word the home run in the first
inning he has homered in each of the
three games of the series
pitch 88
from trevor bauer
to cronenworth
call strike three outside corner that
ends the inning ninth strike out of the
game for bauer
the runs no hits no errors and nobody
left we head to the six with the dodgers
and padres tied at two
two out grisham coming up
here's the one-two to grisham strikes
out swinging
on up that ends the inning tenth strike
out of the game
for trevor bauer
and will go to the seventh this game is
all knotted up at two caratini switch
hitter batting left-handed
high drive right field off the bat of
victor carratini doesn't have enough
it is gone padres take a 3-2 lead
victor caratini with his sixth of the
year off trevor bauer padres
dodgers have the tying running scoring
position with two gone in the eighth for
justin turner
2-2
turner hits a ground ball
right field muncie comes in and ties the
game
justin turner with a two out base hit
it's 3-3 in the eighth
now trent grisham will step to the plate
bases loaded one out tie game
padres dodgers
and a 3-2 to trent christian
that is ball four the padres take the
lead on the one
croninworth will score padres limited
four to three
and victor caratini coming up
carratini to right
beatty
makes the catch
tagging at third as machado he will
score
padres take a 5-3 lead victor caratini
with a sac fly to right field and the
padres have a two-run lead
here we go albert pujols gonna pinch hit
for joe kelly
lined and cocked by machado throw to
second double play
it's the ball game
manny machado who's done it all tonight
does it again his double play ends this
game and the padres sweep the dodgers in
a three-game series they've won seven
straight